let's talk about this
while we're dealing with these formula
shortages and will was able to
accurately articulate you know the
problem that people parents are facing
with the shortage let's talk about
additional ukraine supplemental
appropriations act 40 billion dollars
going to
easter a war in eastern europe to aid a
country that is not a not a nato ally
not an eu member state but for some
reason we should set one of the largest
war packages in history you know what
really freaks me out is this right
here i mean isn't this a little effing
odd that's what i said
every single democrat yay not a single
note not a single one of them
republicans it's like two to one
it's almost like they're gonna get
kickbacks from this or they just hate
the people they claim to represent
they have no concern for protecting
their own countrymen they don't have any
desire to ensure that
the people back home have any kind of
relief it's all about ensuring that
other people imagine being like an
anti-war democrat voter like like
someone who still believes what
democrats believed i don't know a decade
ago
you know it just
i'd be i'd be depressed if i were them
like i think glenn greenwald did a point
the whole squad voted for all this crap
the entirety of the squad look at this
look at this okay so here it is every
single one you i guarantee people who
are listening can name those who voted
no
right i'm gonna guess tom thomas massey
yeah well look thomas massey is right
here as a nay of course you've got uh
marjorie taylor green of course where's
uh where's she yeah she's in here
somewhere um lauren bobert of course
right there saying no
thorn saying no
uh let's see who else jim jordan says no
yeah there's david cawthorne madison
cawthorne where's he at
i guess david cawthorne would be madison
kaufman because it is the same district
not an nc11 oh okay oh is that a middle
name or something oh yeah first name
maybe i don't know
well how about that
clay higgins john rose ronnie jackson
pete sessions
yeah uh just as an aside madison his
name is david madison cawthorne that's
disingenuous that they put him up there
as david and he goes by madison that's
really messed up it was weird yeah i
don't know marjorie green of course
she's right there no i just i just loved
this when i saw glenn greenwald tweet
about it he's like alexandria
ocasio-cortez supporting with the
largest war packages ever it's like
there she is well look every single time
every single time the government fails
to meet the needs of the american people
in some significant way the response
from the left is if we didn't have such
an astronomical defense budget we could
afford to take care of people right now
and in the midst of all these problems
they go you know what let's just uh send
40 billion dollars over here to get
involved in foreign affairs here's what
i love though we have this clip from
bill maher that's been going viral
student loan forgiveness is a loser
issue for the party that wants to win
back the working class and bill makes a
couple good points he's like 13 of
americans have student loan debt
that's not a lot of people
50 of that debt is held by graduate
degrees and he was like come on yeah
he's like these are people who are like
i don't know what else to do i want to
keep going to school because someone
else is paying for it
bill maher saying that and then they all
basically agreed
and so
for me this was actually a convincing
argument i've often said
that i think we should forgive the uh
interest rates
if you borrowed it you got to pay it
back but the interest rates i can
understand are insane after watching
this bill maher segment i'm like nope
never mind i'm done nah sorry it's on
you 13
and half of its graduate degrees
this is what the democrats are focused
on the highest income earners who want a
freebie that's what it is sorry i'm done
they're just giving something to their
voters they're voters of the
professional class right like that's
that's that's
13 of people they're going to win over i
am willing to tolerate loan forgiveness
if we classify the debt as odious and
then go at the universities to get the
payment back right like that's you know
i'm willing to use that because there
you know there are people who like were
genuinely exploited by these
universities and they got degrees that
are worthless and like maybe don't need
to be completely immisrated forever i'm
cool with that but that means that in
the foreign policy context whenever we
forgive somebody else's debt what we're
saying is that's odious debt it should
never have been issued it was wrong to
issue it and we need and we need to go
back and get essentially like
you know go back and get a reimbursement
or forget the exact word what's a
historical example of an odious debt a
debt we would give to like an african
country under a dictator that we'd later
forgive um you know
because the new government took power
what do you think about usury
and which is basically collecting
interest on loans well i mean the
general concept of collecting interest
on loans is i mean i think one
inevitable and two
good because uh otherwise there's never
any loans right you know and money yeah
high value
it used to be the way that there was no
interest and then it was called usury
and it was punishable by death if
someone did that then all of a sudden at
some point in the banking industry
1700's with amshell rothschild or
something they just started maybe way or
that you know loans are very very old
right like you're talking you know if
you're talking loans i don't even know
how old but dead debt is i mean actually
you know people think barter is like the
original transaction that's wrong debt
is yeah favors favors right like that's
the basis for how insurance used to be
if my house burns down i'll owe you one
and so then if your house burns down
i'll like if my house burns down and you
help me in any way i am indebted to you
and it's the expectation the the
expectation that i would then go and
help you in the event of something
similar or repay the favor usually to
clarify is unethical practice of uh
originating a loan with an unreasonably
high interest rate
i guess that's a social conversation no
that's that's my opinion
my concern is
you've got democrats who are in lockstep
voting for war and i think the reason
they do it is they know their voters
don't care about it i don't think aoc
ever was anti-war at all i think she
assumed her base cared about it
now that the media narrative is yay
ukraine they're like okay good now we
can vote for war that's it
so when i hear about this debt
forgiveness stuff i'm like
y'all want 40 billion dollars for war in
ukraine you got it the rest of your debt
sorry no dice you got your war you got
your funding you sent the money that
would have paid off your debts to
raytheon i hope you're happy
congratulations that's 244
yeah no i mean certainly there should be
no talk of of student debt forgiveness
now right like from the allowing
republicans like the idea that they'd
allow any of this to go through from
democrats that they wouldn't um inflict
massive punitary measures right like
i've heard biden's thing about doing it
unilaterally if that were done
then the next time republicans take
power they should just simply end the
student loan program right like we don't
absolutely there's no jubilees it's like
protect and you're protecting your
voters from
the biden in the professional class just
basically looting them right like
because you know
the trump the republican voters like
that's not the professional class and so
basically like
the whole student loan debt forgiveness
is screw over republican voters to
benefit democrat voters like we should
never tolerate that no absolutely not
this sort of goes back to a conversation
we've had a number of times on the show
about the moral foundations and the fact
that the two moral foundations that
people on the left have are care and
fairness and those two values by
themselves
not tempered by other values literally
don't mean anything right so if you're
talking about something like loyalty we
can sort of put somewhat objective
metrics on that right
i would actually say very objective
metrics with care and fairness the way
it's articulated by the left
especially care that can literally just
mean it can literally mean anything like
we have to care about other people we
have to help other people and you don't
have to give a robust argument for why
what you're doing actually will help and
how it won't be of too much negative
consequence to the people who the help
is coming at the expense of right and
they certainly don't and that produces
not only examples like uh
so many senators on the left or i'm
sorry so many political leaders on the
left who have argued against war sending
money to ukraine
it's also a huge part of the reason why
we had a 4.2 trillion dollar bailout and
added an insane percentage of currency
to the money supply over the course of
two years and have runaway inflation as
a result because no one considers the
negative long-term effects of any given
policy prescription because all they
have to say is see look at me i care
look at me i'm doing the thing that's
fair for people what do you think would
happen if red areas stopped trading with
blue areas
like i don't mean state i mean areas
rural illinois was just like we're no
longer going to be doing business with
the city well if rural maryland decided
to stop sending stuff to baltimore i
don't know what would happen it'd be a
mess wouldn't be good i mean this is
where a lot of this stuff comes from we
create a lot of farms around here a lot
of cows a lot of grain i i wonder what
value rural folk get from city folk and
obviously there's like technology
advancements there's insurance companies
there's media and stuff but we're
getting so divided at this point and so
many people are are content with i mean
we're facing decentralization of of the
economy cultural development a lot of
these jobs can be done outside of cities
what is the benefit for anyone any
conservative to do business inside of a
city or with cities when they can
distribute via the internet or through
shipping or whatever
i personally i haven't been to a city in
like in a long time many many months
many many money you end up needing
certain things certain professional
class services right and you think about
uh legal services you end up needing uh
medical services we got lawyers out here
yeah we do i mean you do but like it can
get
i don't know it depends like
there's a reason that like these these
city you know metropolis open up and i
mean you think about a place like
chicago what is chicago built around
well it's the hub of the entire midwest
you know
agriculture uh like that's where the
commodities markets are but i mean i
understand why back in the day
centralization was important so you run
a big farm
you set up your headquarters in chicago
because you can walk 10 feet and there's
the headquarters of another company that
you need to trade with
well now we're doing everything online
well yeah i was just thinking i did
spend time in nashville a very
centralized uh active music scene and
it's kind of like why do we use twitter
when it's we know it's crap because it's
centralized and that's where everyone's
at same with nashville i go there
because that's where they live so
there's this idea that wealth disappears
within three generations when it's
inherited and i almost wonder if we're
asking the same question about many of
these large cities in the sense that
have they given the world something
tremendous in order to start themselves
and become centers of wealth and are
they now more or less squandering that
wealth by doing jobs which are more or
less useless and unnecessary because of
their position within society because
that's often how wealth leaves a family
right the people are insulated from the
realities of what not being productive
results and so they like stop being
productive and eventually lose all their
money that's the story of detroit right
like that's actually a very i mean we we
don't it's hard for us to understand but
detroit used to be like
the up-and-coming economic center of the
country the third biggest you know city
you know and like one of the you know i
mean detroit shrunk massively but when
you know in the car heyday of the car
industry pre-silicon valley like detroit
was the place to go if you were a young
person you know the economic engine of
the country the silicon valley of its
time and now it's not
um
you know there's i think there's a
natural life cycle to these things you
know you have some wildly profitable
powerful innovative industry in your
economic area it allows the government
to get away with all sorts of
shenanigans and still have you know the
place function pretty well
but if that industry declines
things fall apart really quick thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm we'll see
you all there